Donald Trump's chief of staff Reince
Priebus or as I call him rinse Priebus
has admitted that Donald Trump I hope
you're sitting down for this that Donald
Trump is considering clamping down on
the first amendment which you might be
aware of provides for freedom of speech
unimpeded by the government yesterday
morning there was an exchange between
ABC's Jonathan Karl and White House
chief of staff
rinse Priebus and previous said in no
uncertain terms that yes the White House
is toying with the idea of changing or
even uh abolishing the First Amendment
through what they all agree would be
necessary which would be a
constitutional amendment and why what
has caused this negative or critical
press coverage of Donald Trump is making
them explore a constitutional amendment
to limit press speech when I saw the
headline Pat I thought it's exaggerated
right this is it's probably just limited
to libel laws or something like that
right wrong they are thinking about a
constitutional amendment to control
speech all there was what he said about
opening up the lot libel laws tweeting
the failing New York Times has disgraced
the media world got me wrong for two
solid years change the libel laws that
would require as I understand it a
constitutional amendment is he really
going to pursue that is that something
he wants to pursue I think it's
something that we've looked at and how
that gets executed or whether that goes
anywhere it's a different story but when
you have articles out there that have no
basis or fact and we're sitting here on
24/7 cable companies writing stories
about constant contacts with Russia and
all these other matters I think the
president should be lost who they were
talking stories avoiding I think that I
think that newspapers and news agencies
need to be more responsible with how
they report the news I am so I don't
think anybody would disagree with that
about whether or not the president
should ever write I already answered the
question I said this is something that
is being looked at but it's something
the
as far as how it gets executed where we
go in it that's another issue there are
articles Trump doesn't like so he's
looking at constitutional amendment to
limit press freedom Jonathan Karl
accurately pointed out that in order to
do that in order to do what they're
talking about you would have to amend
the constitution is that what you mean
rinse yes it is says rinse previs and
you know conservatives always make the
argument that liberals are trying to
attack or even repeal the Second
Amendment when you propose something as
simple as background check for everyone
which none of them have admitted to yeah
now you have the chief of staff of the
president verbatim saying that he wants
to take a look at repealing the First
Amendment or making some sort of change
to it and the reason that they're
looking at that is what's even more
disturbing the fact that there's
articles that contradict what Trump
would like to see written no matter what
your political orientation you need to
be concerned about this you need to be
scared about this really scared if you
don't care now because it's Trump and
your right-wing media what about when
Trump isn't president anymore remember
the First Amendment says quote Congress
shall make no law respecting an
establishment of religion or prohibiting
the free exercise thereof or abridging
the freedom of speech or of the press or
the right of the people peaceably to
assemble and to petition the government
for redress of grievances is there any
silver lining here I'm reaching deep
here okay if Trump can't manage to get a
bill through a republican-controlled
Congress to repeal the Affordable Care
Act
maybe we can assume he wouldn't be able
to manage the constitutional
constitutional amendment process but
even if he were to get some kind of
compromise half-measure this is the
stuff of Horrors and also it was oh it
was always very bizarre to me when Trump
would talk about opening up the libel
laws yeah he was at his rallies as if
that affects the average individual in
Pennsylvania or Michigan that's just
something that he wants to do to make
his own image look better it's to
suppress press freedom no doubt about it
yeah your the the average worker in pens
vania as you're pointing out libel laws
to sue media outlets I mean what are we
even talking about as if the media is
doing stories on them in particular
which Trump supporters will show up on
cable news to defend us the fact that
Reince Priebus is even willing to
publicly admit to this shows how out
there these people are the
administration is talking about
curtailing free speech through
constitutional amendments and they're
willing to admit it if I were thinking
about doing something like this the last
thing I would do is admit it on national
television
especially because the First Amendment
those six rights are the bedrock of our
democracy and without those you don't
have much else apparently not apparently
not when the New York had when the
failing New York Times writes a negative
story about you and of course I I almost
feel silly mentioning this but I know if
I don't it might appear as though my
criticism is not complete most of those
stories Trump is angry about are are
accurate stories right I mean the idea
that there's just completely fabricated
stories about Trump on respectable media
yes we're dealing with fake news and
we're dealing with propaganda use the
left and the right are dealing with that
and we've talked about that but the idea
that the New York Times is just
publishing made-up nonsense it's of
course not true and I I guess I should
just say that to get it on the record as
part of the story and when he talked
about opening up the libel laws he
doesn't say it so that these media
outlets can't say things that are
inaccurate he says that it's so they
can't say things that are negative
towards him and that is completely
consistent with Sean Spicer's
perspective remember the press gaggle
where he didn't invite in certain media
outlets and he said straight up we're
not going to invite people in that are
just telling these stories and crafting
these narratives period so there's no
even a public assertion that it's merely
when someone makes something up it's
narratives that they don't like no
matter what your political perspective
is this is something you should be
horrified about send me your thoughts
about it I'm on Twitter at the Pakman
the show is on Twitter a David Pakman
show